as vladimir putin commemorated those who
died in the siege of leningrad in the
second world war his military had all
but encircled ukraine
the russian government has repeatedly
said it has no intention of launching an
invasion
but the option
seems to be there
philosophically we're usually bad at
predicting war we usually get it wrong
either we think it won't happen but it
does or we think it will happen but it
doesn't and we were surprised when putin
moved into crimea in 2014 we were
surprised when russia moved into georgia
in 2008 we were surprised when russia
moved into syria in 2015. this time
putin is giving us weeks of notice so
maybe he's got something else in mind
there you go well putin's views on
ukraine are well known
he's often repeated them
we cannot be concerned by the prospect
of ukraine joining nato because it will
lead without a doubt to the deployment
of troops military bases and threatening
us with weapons there
when the soviet union broke up in 1991
russia lost control of 14 former
republics
the loss of ukraine was the hardest pill
to swallow ukraine as i see it ukraine
is the key factor in the failure to
reunite the soviet union
i don't mean that literally but in
putin's attempt to recreate a certain
unity or union based around the former
republics ukraine isn't interested in
this and that remains a major problem
for putin
putin has tried to keep ukraine close
before in 2013 under russian pressure
then president viktor yanukovych
rejected closer ties with the eu
that prompted nationwide protests
resulting in yanukovych's downfall
months later putin annexed crimea
the long-term goal of putin and his
elite is russia's isolation from the
west that's non-western development and
in this sense ukraine which is closely
connected to russia culturally is a
window to the west and as so is an
eyesore for putin
vladimir putin has described russians
and ukrainians as one people who share a
single historic and spiritual space
he doesn't want to lose that connection
though that might not be the view of
many ukrainians
bernard smith al jazeera
let's bring in russian affairs analyst
vladimir sodnikov from moscow good to
have you with us sir uh what in your
opinion russia's intentions regarding
ukraine what is this military build up
at the border for
the doctrine uh at my opinion actually
there is no question of any aggression
uh on behalf of russia any
russians intention to
invade ukraine to make even ex
concussions i think that the whole
question is revolving around
the issue of uh expanding the nato and
the the probable uh participation of
ukraine in in the enlargement of nature
this is one thing another thing i think
that
this is the controversial question of
putting
uh u.s and nato medium and shorter range
missiles on the ukrainian territory this
is the question which is very much
worrying moscow and moscow doesn't want
to have these missiles
practical on its border because the
flying time
uh then would be uh three to five
minutes and this is a serious question
for moscow and another another thing
also is that
if you remember back in history
uh these missiles
could resemble the situation which was
when the soviet union was existing in
1982 in 1983 nato decided to put
medium and shorter range on the
russian western border in nato country
so and russia and the soviet union
retaliate so i think this is not the
question of any retaliation from russia
but the question of a security situation
so this ongoing military presence on the
border with ukraine is all about
president putin trying to force
concessions from the west over nato
uh you might say so but actually not
only concessions another thing that
russia would very much like that uh
ukraine uh
resume uh will resume the
uh its participation in the minsk format
negotiations and i think that this
question would be discussed probably if
there will be another uh summit between
uh president putin and president biden
so not on the security situation but
also the situation in general i mean uh
when i'm saying in general i mean that
uh russia actually would like
to have not only guarantees but also uh
to be sure that its eastern neighbor is
not hostile to here so i mean why is
russia so opposed to neighbours becoming
part of native nato you talk about them
uh being hostile nato would argue that
the troops and missiles are only on its
eastern boundary as a deterrent and for
detense at defence purposes only against
an expansionist russia
well actually russia is not uh unsure at
all that and
of course it's not that the policy of
so-called expansionism actually
uh is forcing the west to deter russia
russia thinks on uh vice versa russia
russia thinks that this is
are aggressive plans against a russian
identity against russian security so i
think that uh
at the end of a time
russia would like as i said
they friendly ukraine not the country
which will be
participating in any plans which russia
thinks can be uh in a nato country's
mind
good to talk to you so many thanks
indeed for being with us vladimir
sotnikov there live in moscow
thank you